hopefully you have done your research
hopefully you know what you're in for
if you don't know what you're in for my
friend will eat your chickens
[Music]
hey everyone i'm brad i'm the head of
continental hustle i'm joined tonight by
carolyn dohak one of our
uh longest serving and most entertaining
writers who does a lot of work for the
daily
and this week she's got a sunday story
for us um
welcome to the show caroline thanks for
having me brad
you bet so um we've written about people
who have
are baking their own bread and we've
written about people who are doing a lot
more gardening
and lots of do-it-yourself trends and
this week caroline has a story about
chicken rearing and i wonder caroline
you're
um in the missouri area where did you
find the chicken story for us
sure so um i'm a have been a chicken
wrangler in the past not at the moment
but
i was just scrolling facebook one day
and
a friend who lives out of town
had posted that
anyone who had panic bought chickens and
found them overwhelming
was welcome to donate them to her
however people needed to know that she
already had a full flock of laying hens
and any chickens that they donated she
was going to slaughter and eat them
so that's how you stumble upon the story
you realize this is
that there's panic buying happening yeah
i hadn't heard of that
and um i mean urban hens have been
popular for a while
and and so i looked into it
and yeah this has been a thing
turns out it is a thing now and there's
a there's a whole economy around it and
so
what is the um what is the business of
raising chickens look like both for the
consumer
and for the businesses as much as you
know at this point
if you are in the business of
selling baby chicks
or chicken products this is a great time
for you
you are seeing compared with last year
your sales have increased hundreds of
percentages
it's awesome if you are someone who has
panic
purchased chickens hopefully you have
done your research
hopefully you know what you're in for if
you don't know what you're in for
my friend will eat your chickens um
but the thing is you're not
going to break even on your investment
and you're not going to have
a steady stream of eggs not for a while
because your chicks will have to mature
but also they go through awkward molting
phases
and they don't lay in the winter
but you do get these amazing eggs like
fresh laid eggs
and you have these chickens running
around your backyard so is it worth the
hassle i mean
obviously you're gonna explore this a
little bit in the story but it
doesn't make a lot of money for you but
you get these nice eggs
i mean personally i think so um the eggs
are far superior to
what you get at the store the yolks are
orange
um they just they just stand up
in in the pan um
there's some research on the omega
whatever levels that shows that they're
more nutritious
um the chickens are fun you know you
look out your window and you see these
little
triangles and they're moving around and
they have personalities and um
they're very and that's really
fun and uh your neighbors
will like you a lot more i have found i
was concerned
when i first got into it that they would
not but
they like it and if you share with them
you become very popular
exactly share some eggs you've had some
uh it sounds like some entertaining
battles in your yard with chickens tell
us about like your favorite story about
one of your chickens and what some of
the names are
oh sure so um my husband
is an early 90s hip hop
aficionado and so a lot of our chickens
have hip hop or rnb inspired names
and we got our first batch um
we got six of them and
little kim died of unnatural causes
we're not sure what um lp
was killed by a raccoon
which was very messy so we got two new
ones to replace them
um mary j blige and pharrell
and it was the girl who was on the like
just
the very lowest point in the pecking
order she was very insecure
and she started pecking the new girls
like in the neck
and she actually packed a hole in mary j
blige's neck
and the thing is you don't you don't
want that because if they get a taste
for one another's flesh they will
cannibalize
it's very gross so your choices there
are you can clip their beaks which i'm
not into
you can kill the chicken which i'm not
into or you can get these things called
penless peepers so they're bot they're
blinders but they look like kanye west
sunglasses right and they
they fit into the nostrils on the top of
the beak it's completely humane
and um they keep the chicken from seeing
straight ahead so she can't attack but
she can still see well enough that she
can pack and
scratch and bite so um salt and pepper
had to wear these for a while while they
um
got used to pharrell and mary j blige
and
it took a little while and
they got over it but that was
that was a thing for a while that's
fantastic i
i can't wait to read your story there's
so much more to hear about the chicken
business
how you raise them how lovely they can
be and then
also there are some very troubling
things which you will talk about in the
story i'm not gonna let you tell
tell everyone now but uh make sure you
open the email on sunday you will love
caroline doheck's
first sunday story and thanks for tuning
in everyone
thank you so much